Hey welcome to the team Coco 24-hour
mobile gaming marathon look at this oh
yeah yeah right on can have gum here
I'll just hold that
listen let me explain something just
hold that for 24 hours okay hold that
all right so I thought we'd play a game
to start things off it's called Monument
Valley to going ultra instinct just like
someone on the internet told him to do
Thomas someone Conan will never meet
someone Conan will never know Adam says
Conan my hair I want to see some of the
sweet dance moves there's no music to
dance to you don't just know listen this
a theory listen there's ethereal music
on the game oh this is I feel
uncomfortable it's very this is very
Kraftwerk this is very very slow and
it's the kind of music
are you doing I was just protecting my I
was I thought that was a setup for you
punching me I thought it was like a
elaborate setup that you were just gonna
don't god yes
Conan I adore your abusive nature yes
way I really do love you
people think don't see the way he
cringes when I pat him on the back that
means I've never heard him in his life
Moses storm everybody Moses story where
we together I might know me from the
comment section
[Applause]
what kitchen is this that has a knife
sticking out of the wall just doing this
cleanup or if one of those lenses
sausages run through close to die here
it's gonna happen any second we're not
even halfway through baby we're only
we're only point word point forty puts
out a word not even halfway through so
don't worry about it somebody do the
math on that we got five more minutes is
incredible twenty no one's ever done
anything for 24 hours in human history
it's true this is a whole new level I
got my hair doing look at that you know
I think I do big people I hate to do
this to you kind of I think people would
love to envision to touch your hair
again because what they weren't here the
very beginning of this stream I think
it'd be great right grab that virtually
guys get all the way up to the screen
this into a time graphic this is
definitely the end of a 24 hours dream
you know there's a lot of people that
said there's no way you could pull this
off and then there was a lot yeah then
there's a lot of other people that said
what do you mean it's quite common on
the show today you know I'm really glad
you asked because I don't know we've had
a good show man did you check out our
Monday show Oh incredible tell him that
was so good wait our Monday this past
Monday that's funny the show that we did
yes that decided we had it was great to
me
Kevin Hart was I was about to say
cameras still good you would not pass a
sobriety test right gonna end on that
everybody that's my [ __ ] thank you for
watching what seen it mobile marathon go
to sleep
[Applause]